in der nacht es ist in hamburg vor dem
elbtunnel zu einem schweren autounfall
gekommen
der fahrer wird dabei so heftig in
seinem auto eingeklemmt dass die 35
feuerwehrleute über eine stunde brauchen
um ihn zu befreien um 3 uhr 15 wird die
feuerwehr zu dem unfall auf der a7
gerufen
die einsatzkräfte treffen auf einen
wagen mit totalschaden der fahrer ist
eingeklemmt
der pkw ist aufgrund des vorliegenden
fall hergang ist schwerst deformiert
geworden so dass die person im bereich
der beine schwerst eingeklemmten wird
die person war die ganze zeit
ansprechbar auch während der gesamten
technischen rettung
die einsatzkräfte haben daraufhin
umgehend die red und schließlich die
notärztliche versorgung des patienten
eingeleitet parallel dazu wurden in
absprache mit den vor ort anwesenden
montag zudem technische fette und
vorbereitet aufgrund dieser schweren die
information ist pkws haben wir dauerten
diese arbeiten insgesamt weit über eine
stunde wo der pkw bietet mit
rettungsschere und rettungsspreizer so
vorbereitet wurde das für den patienten
letztendlich möglichst schonend aus dem
pkw einkommen
er soll mit seinem ford focus
anscheinend versucht haben einen lkw zu
überholen doch die fahrbahn wird von
einem baustellenfahrzeug verengt der
fordfahrer kraft in dieses
absicherungsfahrzeug der
autobahnmeisterei
dann dreht sich der wagen trifft noch
auf einen weiteren lkw und bleibt dann
an der leitplanke stehen erst nach über
einer stunde kann der schwer verletzte
mann aus dem wrack befreit werden
die polizei ermittelt zur zeit noch die
genaue unfallursache
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren